[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce premier
numéro de dimanche en politique de
l'année 2020 avec les équipes qui
préparait réalise cette émission je vous
présente des voeux de belle et heureuse
année l'actualité de la semaine aura été
marquée par une alternance de journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites et de négociations entre le
gouvernement et les partenaires sociaux
avec un premier ministre qui tente de
sortir du conflit et des syndicats qui
continuent de maintenir la pression sur
l'exécutif alors le gouvernement doit-il
s'attendre à une année sociale en 2020
comment sortir de la crise du conflit
des retraites
peut-il éteindre les flammes des
différents conflits sociaux quelles
peuvent être les autres combats qui
attendent partenaires sociaux et
majorité présidentielle dans les
prochains mois on en débat ce matin en
direct avec nos invités didier martin
bonjour bon je vous êtes député la
république en marche de côte-d'or vous
nous direz notamment comment la majorité
va avancer pour réformer le pays
après les mouvements des gilet jaune et
des retraites sandrine mourey bonjour
vous êtes secrétaire départementale de
la cgt en côte d'or avec vous on verra
notamment
quel est le moral des troupes après plus
d'un mois de conflit et si d'autres
conflits se prépare jean philippe
richard bon jour où je vous êtes le
président du medef bourgogne franche
comté après les dernières annonces la
d'edouard philippe sur l'âge déquilibre
vous nous direz si vous êtes prêt à
reprendre les discussions
on évoquera aussi la situation des
entreprises dans la région après toutes
ces journées de conflit denis dubé
natale bonjour je vous êtes militant de
la france a soumises en côte d'or on
verra avec vous si ces mobilisations
vont se poursuivre en 2020 et si elles
peuvent aussi influencer la vie
politique et les municipales et vous qui
nous regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
commenter en direct cette émission sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag dit
mme paul bourgogne alors une réaction
sandrine mourey bien sûr l'actualité
celle annonces du premier ministre le
retrait de l'âge pivot de 64 ans dans le
projet de réforme des retraites sous
conditions et la balle va être dans le
camp des partenaires sociaux est ce que
vous vous dites pas aller ils l'ont ils
ont tendu la main ils ont fait un pas
aujourd'hui déjà premièrement
effectivement on voit bien que le
gouvernement
dos au mur face aux mobilisations depuis
plus d'un mois est contraint à un monde
et de faire quelques marches arrière et
il voit bien il constate bien que ce
projet de réforme de dons on discute
depuis plus de deux ans le projet de loi
qui vient de sortir là on a fait
l'analyse et les mobilisations qui
s'ensuivent les salariés ont bien
compris que ce projet de loi par essence
il va participer à baisser le niveau des
pensions et baisser les droits
le gouvernement vient d'annoncer
effectivement le retrait de l'âge pivot
assez bien attention attention le diable
se cache dans les détails de la lettre
du premier ministre effectivement il
parle bien un d'un retrait provisoire de
l'âge pivot sur les mesures d' équilibre
à court terme ça ne figurera pas dans ce
projet de loi ça veut dire que dans le
deuxième
après le projet de loi donc après les
mesures définitives d' équilibre se dire
après 2027
il le précise bien dans son article 4 1
l'âge pivot est bien maintenu il retire
provisoirement laissant aux partenaires
sociaux jeudi aux organisations
syndicales et organisations patronales
le soin d'eux travaille à des mesures
d'équilibré six mois 2010 4 10 il
effectivement 18 mois d'avril donc on
voit bien que c'est un retrait
provisoire conditionnée à deux points
c'est à dire que les partenaires sociaux
devront trouver des mesures d' équilibre
sans recourir à la baisse des pensions
bien évidemment mais ça augmenter les
recettes sans augmenter le coût du
travail c'est à dire que d'entrée on
vous dit quoi en fait c'est l'âge pivot
d'entrée il coupe un l'augmentation des
cotisations et 2 la possibilité
d'augmenter les salaires disait martin
finalement tout ça pour ça il fallait le
retirer bien avant cet âge pivot pour
calmer tout le monde et notamment les
syndicats dits réformistes comme la cfdt
et l'unsa d'ailleurs plusieurs de vos
collègues députés cette semaine ont
demandé au gouvernement de retirer cet
âge pivot de ce projet de retraite
projet de réforme oui nous sommes
aujourd'hui à un tournant parce que les
échanges ont été nombreux y compris
pendant la période des fêtes
même si ces échanges étaient à ce
moment-là informel la reprise des
échanges formels c'est cette année et là
sur la table une avancée du gouvernement
et une proposition d'un plusieurs
organisations syndicales en faveur de la
réouverture du dialogue
nous devons reprendre le dialogue cette
réforme
elle est nécessaire la population
vieillit la durée de vie est allongée
nous avons un croisement entre les
actifs et les inactifs
il faut garantir l'avenir il faut
protéger ces courriers c'était un point
de communication
est ce que vous dites c'est dommage nous
a mis cet âge pivot au coeur d'une
réforme qui n'était pas finalement sur
la question de l'équilibré des comptes
des retraites mais qui était sur un
autre projet qui était plus une forme de
justice c'était ce qui était demandé aux
17 une forme de justice c'est deuxième
point important nécessaire à cause de
l'évolution démographique justice est
nécessaire pourquoi parce que vous avez
aujourd'hui des personnes en particulier
des femmes aux carrières hachées qui
sont obligés de travailler jusqu'à 67
ans l'âge pivot est une façon pas la
seule de faire que ces femmes-là de 67
arrêteront demain à 64 ans après
négociation c'est la fin des retraites
en dessous de 1000 euros et 2 des
recettes des retraites que je dirais
nini mal et même indigne c'est la fin de
ronde il carrières hachées
c'est la fin du calcul de retraite très
inégal entre six derniers meilleur mois
pour certains et 25 meilleures années
c'est la fin également de droit du
travail en général c'est la fin d'une
multitude de régimes ce qu'on appelle
les régimes spéciaux qui aurait
aujourd'hui inventé au début du 20e 21e
siècle
quarante et quelques régimes spéciaux
est différent entre les uns et les
autres
denis glénat terme quand on entend
didier martin c'est le projet de loi
rêver qui va permettre plus de justice
sociale finalement entre les uns et les
autres ça devrait plaire à la france a
soumise c'est fantastique c'est
fantastique c'est que depuis 2003 on a
eu un paquet de réformes sur les
retraites
et à chaque fois on nous dit c'est la
dernière mais moi je suis bien curieux
de savoir s'il disait martin est capable
de nous dire combien de trimestres on va
travailler lorsqu'on est née après 75 ou
après 1980 quelle sera la valeur du
point et quel sera le montant des
pensions
à l'issue de sa
très simplement vous faites partie des
gens qui disent c'est encore très fou on
ne sait pas ce qu'il ya derrière
on sait absolument pas ce qui revient on
connaît pas la valeur du point est la
valeur du point va se négocier
potentiellement avec les partenaires
sociaux ou pas on ne sait pas au trou où
ça va aller donc le gouvernement s'est
engagé à ce que le point ne baisse pas
oui mais le coût de la vie le coût de la
vie augmente il ya un effet de
l'inflation aussi mais qui retraite sur
le coût de la vie sur les prix et chaque
période travaillée ouvrera à des droits
nouveaux pour la retraite
c'est ça la différence jean philippe
richard est ce que le medef est soulagé
aujourd'hui après l'annonce d'edouard
philippe du retrait de l'âge pivot au
coeur de ce ce projet de réforme des
retraites
soulagé si effectivement elle annonce
peut permettre de remettre la france au
travail entre guillemets autres
guillemets oui bien sûr bon après sou et
le medef
j'ai comme comme comme les autres mais
on fait de ce dossier une question de
bon sens quoi par rapport aux paramètres
qui nous sont laissés pour améliorer
effectivement pour répondre donc à ce
dossier
l'âge pivot l'âge pivot moi je préférais
effectivement parler d'annahj déquilibre
bosser c'est exactement comme le
gouvernement le tard peut-être mais tout
simplement parce qu'une des premiers à
mesure mais d'ailleurs qui a été annoncé
par par premier ministre c'est de ne pas
toucher et de ne pas toucher
effectivement aux hauts taux de
prélèvement des entreprises donc puisque
vous savez comme moi que la fiscalité
pour les entreprises en france est une
des plus élevées par rapport aux pays
aux autres pays de cd v cdh en salle est
donc pas le coût du travail oui c'est
important pour pour nous d'entendre ça
parce que sinon ce serait dramatique si
effectivement vous devez toucher à la
fiscalité augmenter la fiscalité ce
serait dramatique pour pour pour
l'emploi donc dans notre pays vous êtes
prêt à vous remettre autour de la table
d'ici mois d'avril pour travailler sur
cette question d' équilibre des comptes
des retraites
oui bien sûr sans aucun problème la cgt
aussi alors la cgt
décidée au regard de la lettre un album
décidé collectivement de la sa
participation bien évidemment on va le
décider avec nos organisations et avec
les syndiqués on ne décide pas tout seul
ceci étant je tiens à rappeler que
depuis le début des rencontres est
monsieur delevoye et dernièrement sur la
dernière rencontre avec à matignon on a
mis sur la table des propositions de
financement donc de nouvelles recettes
je tiendrai comme a précisé que le
conseil d'orientation des retraites a
bien stipulé que les déficits ou les
déséquilibre des régimes de retraite ne
viennent pas de trop de dépenses mais de
manque de recettes c'est le corps qui le
dit donc nous la cgt on a fait des
propositions d'augmentation des recettes
pour garantir à tout et à tout moment
alors que plusieurs pistes
il ya plusieurs pistes il ya des pistes
effectivement d'augmentation des
cotisations par salariales et patronales
il n'y a pas que la cgt qui fait cette
proposition y compris dans d'autres
organisations syndicales que vous dit
réformiste
je tiens à préciser que la cgt et pour
des réformes également mais pour des
réformes de progrès social il y a
effectivement des propositions
concernant les exonérations de
cotisations des entreprises elles font
foison et par exemple on avait ciblé de
manière symbolique vous avez par exemple
les entreprises du cac 40 ou par les
grosses entreprises en ont fait pâle
amalgame entre eux les petites tpe et
les grosses entreprises les entreprises
du cac 40 bénéficie d'exonérations soi
disant nous de l'emploi si on les
supprime parce qu'elles ont les moyens
si on les supprime est ça rapporterait
plus de 6 milliards d'euros pour les
caisses de retraite on a fait plusieurs
propositions comme l'augmentation des
salaires au nom de nantes les salaires
et bien effectivement ça peut apporter
de reçus on a fait plusieurs
propositions que l'on a mis sur la table
certaines rejoignent d'autres
organisations
je tiens à rappeler que sur la réforme
il n'y a pas que la cgt qui oppose à
cette réforme et qui fait des
propositions et à la cgt force ouvrière
la cftc
les cards également solidaires fsu donc
on voit bien qu'il ya encore des cadres
on va laisser répond didier martin et
jean philippe richard bien sûr bien on
connaît bien le discours de
l'organisation qui représente madame
mouret c'est pas notre option c'est pas
notre option
notre option c'est qu'il y ait davantage
de personnes qui travaillent
retour à l'emploi si possible au plein
emploi notre option c'est ne pas
augmenter les cotisations des
entreprises d'aucune entreprise
aucune entreprise nous aimons bien les
pme mais nous aimons bien aussi des
grandes entreprises sur cadremploi
beaucoup d'employés donc ne pas
augmenter les moyens qui doivent pas ne
pas augmenter les cotisations des
entreprises et faire qu'ils aient le
plein emploi mais alors comme ça l'a
fait sciemment pour faire rentrer de
l'argent dans les caisses parce que ça
ils vont en parler jeudi six mois
davantage de personnes qui cotisent
c'est à dire le plein-emploi remonter
les corps n'étaient l'égalité sanaa est
d'accord que l'on peut se retrouver sur
l'égalité salariale
par exemple sur martin alors si vous
avez du salariat aux bienfaits du
travail vous permettez qu'on fasse vivre
sans sa démocratie politique en même
temps que la démocratie sociale donc
notre option elle est économique
la première partie du quinquennat était
de relancer la machine dont économique
voilà en simplifiant en réduisant les
charges des entreprises et en favorisant
la formation leur tour les 15 milliards
sur l'apprentissage savez jamais été
fait dont 2 milliards pour la prod
l'enveloppent confié dans les quartiers
politique de la ville
on attend des fonds n'a compris que vous
misez sur la reprise de l'économie
absolument richard nous dira si si
l'économie reprend et si les entreprises
vont bien malgré les conflits mais il
jean philippe richard répondait à
sandrine mourey elle met sur la table
des propositions vous allez en discuter
jusqu'au mois d'avril j'ai pas
l'impression que vous soyez bien
d'accord si vous voulez les entreprises
donc déjà par rapport à l a mise en
place de la loi pacte donc depuis 2014
les entreprises ont créé 9 190 mille
emplois
enfin aller on est presque au fameux
million de votre ancien président du
medef ce soit au pit se développent une
sa date mais on a fini par y arrive donc
à ses 980 emplois et conduit vous parler
effectivement bien évidemment que c'est
une piste mais je vous dis après on est
au risque d'enrayer la machine en terme
d'augmentation de salaire entre 2018 et
2019 19 milliards de documentation de
salaires qui ont été versées aux
collaborateurs il faut voir sur les dix
il faut voir à quel niveau effectivement
il ya des études économistes il faut
bien voir que l'augmentation des
salaires de la masse salariale
ok banco mais sur quelle des cils c'est
notamment l'augmentation des plus hauts
salaires qui a eu lieu effectivement
et quand on regarde il faut et qu il
faut étudier les deux augmentations du
salaire moyen est l'augmentation du
salaire médian et on voit bien que c'est
le salaire moyen qui augmente ça veut
dire que ce sont les plus hauts revenus
qui bénéficient en fait au moins d'un
seul salaire alors que ça même si on
prend le salaire médian il bien on voit
on voit qu'il stagne tu dire que 50% des
salariés touchent moins de 1700 euros
par mois et celui lice celui là il
stagne mais le gouvernement a pris des
mesures avec la prime d'activité bien
laborieux marqué nous n'avons pas voulu
charger les dépenses des entreprises
avec l'augmentation arbitraire des
salaires en revanche avec la prennent
des activités pour un salaire au smic
c'est 241 euros de plus par mois qui ont
été alloués et pour un couple c'est
environ 400 euros un couple avec deux
enfants 400e
donc voilà dix à pouvoir d'achat
supplémentaire prime d'accord il était
allé à l'air elle compte dans le calcul
des retraites est ce qu on entend des
rires des retraites elle compte dans
lequel elle compte dans le calcul des
revenus et du pouvoir d'achat
oui aujourd'hui c'est que veulent
aujourd'hui les salariés veulent du
pouvoir d'achat ils savent qu'ils auront
des efforts et travailler un peu plus
parce que effectivement les entreprises
emploient davantage les ont créés avec
les entreprises devront observer
globalement 540 mille emplois créés
depuis le début de ce quinquennat mais
nous savons que pour l' équilibre à
venir et à négocier avec les partenaires
sociaux
l'équilibré des retraites il faudra
demander à travailler un peu plus c'est
ça la mesure denis dubé natale il
continue son
conflit sur les retraites où il s'arrête
ce matin pour ma part je pense très
clairement qu'ils continuent et je
voudrais revenir un petit peu sur ce que
disait digne et martin brusque paradoxal
qu en dix ans depuis 2018
on a une augmentation du chômage des
plus de 50 ans a été multiplié par 3 on
est passé de 7 145 1000e je crois
demandeurs d'emploi de plus de 50 ans a
mis en quatre
donc on nous demande à la fois de
travailler plus longtemps mais il n'y a
pas d'emploi pour les plus de 50 ans et
sur les créations d'emplois il faudrait
qu'à venir boire un petit peu ce qui a
été créé comme emploi c'est beaucoup de
précarité beaucoup de cdd très peu de
cdi des gens qui sont diplômés qui
n'arrive pas à se stabiliser qui
n'arrivent pas à trouver un travail
stable et sûr le concernant les
retraites et sur le débat c'est qu'on
n'arrive même pas à anticiper de ce
qu'on va pouvoir avoir je veux bien sûr
seul sur ce débat que vous ouvrez sur la
question + 8 % d'apprentis en 2018
ça c'est un chiffre alors effectué un
grand gain dans la nuit en hausse de +
d'emploi des seniors problème
donc c'est la cour des comptes et c'est
pas la france a souhaité lundi c'est la
cour des comptes qui a interpellé le
premier ministre au mois d'octobre sur
julien matin du rsa si vous avez bien lu
la lettre du premier ministre
cette question de l'emploi des seniors
elle figure la question de la pénibilité
elle figure donc nous avons devant nous
l'effet dure et c'est bien la jirs
dessus jusqu'à y compris la fin du mois
d'avril pour l'équilibré financier nous
avons une période pour aborder et
balayer tous et sur sa figure mais on
sait pas encore quelle forme ça va
prendre très concrètement il s'est
souvent en recherche dialogue social
c'est souvent un reproche c'est flou et
comme disait martine aubry à une époque
quand c'est flou c'est qu'il ya un loup
jean paul lejeune
en 10 ans le taux d'emploi des seniors a
donc d
nos collaborateurs nos concitoyens qui
sont âgés entre 50 et 64 ans est passée
de 53 3% à 61 5 % il ya eu des efforts
de fait aimer mais j'en conviens avec
vous il ya certainement encore plein de
plein de choses à inventer dans vos
entreprises par exemple il ya des
tensions sur les seniors mais quand même
une volonté de dire qu'à un moment donné
quand on a dépassé 50 ans 50 50
on est un peu sur la fin donc bon bah si
on si on peut les pousser vers la sortie
c'est mieux le monde du travail c'est
aussi ça la réalité que que vivent ceux
qui nous écoutent parfois c'est aussi ça
les pousser vers la sortie je suis pas
sûr que ce soit comme ça que nos chers
notre poule mais sa direction a forcé
l'entraîneur meilleure chose est
certaine c'est que de gros efforts sont
à faire pour favoriser le retour à
l'emploi
effectivement des seniors les
entreprises sont sont effectivement
disposé à s'y employer
aussi pour papa pas par philanthropie
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya aussi une
réflexion de main d'oeuvre donc il ya
l'affiché donc il ya certainement encore
voilà parmi les qualifiés parmi ces
personnes pour de la formation
professionnelle à venir attendez je vais
jouer à finir juste sur ma lancée
donc il ya plein de choses à faire par
rapport à ça après si vous voulez vous
vous dites réticences il n'ya pas une
volonté des entreprises de sortie à
l'essai il ya peut-être une réticence à
des rentrées
alors pourquoi pas parce que il ya
effectivement toute la problématique des
accidents du travail
deux des modèles de la maladie
professionnelle il ya peut-être des
choses à revoir par radio est peut-être
plus cher quelqu'un qui a effectivement
il ya une angoisse qui s'instaure dans
la tête du jeune entreprise d'embaucher
un monsieur 50 55 ans qui a passé toute
sa vie à se dire est-ce que c'est pas
moi qui vais récupérer vos réponses
je vais faire sur sur trois points déjà
je vais répondre à monsieur martin
puisqu'il nous parle de l'égalité
salariale femmes en banco banco
donc demain vous inscrivez dans la loi
l'égalité salariale femmes-hommes
obligatoires banco je vous prends au mot
1 ont fait on est d'accord là-dessus
rossinien
deuxièmement sur l'emploi des seniors je
passe rapidement il ya un précédent
premièrement effectivement tous les
salariés qui font valoir leurs droits à
la retraite pour un sur deux ne sont
plus dans l'emploi ils sont aux minima
sociaux ou au chômage ou en invalidité
ou sans revenus et sur la pénibilité
ayant un précédent rappelez-vous le
contrat de génération rappelé le contrat
de génération où effectivement les
entreprises devaient garder un senior
un salarié qualifié et en même temps
d'embaucher un jeune que s'est il passé
à peine 20% l'objectif du gouvernement
qui était mis en place vous comprenez
bien qu'on sont un peu sceptiques oui il
faut garder les seniors parce que
effectivement ils ont la qualification
ils ont l'expérience mais on voit bien
que les entreprises
c'est là et sur la pénibilité
effectivement le jeu revient sur le
projet de loi le gouvernement en
arrivant on en a déjà parlé monsieur
martin a supprimé 4 critères de
pénibilité
4 et pas des moindres le port de charges
lourdes les postures pénibles les
vibrations les produits chimiques
prenons un métier par exemple celui du
bâtiment les salariés du bâtiment
tous les métiers du bâtiment ils sont
pénibles
ils ont tous ces quatre critères de
pénibilité il faut les réintroduire est
considéré la pénibilité avec un départ
anticipé métier j'en apprenais
l'égoutier prenez un égoutier à 17 ans
d'espérance de vie en moins le temps
passant on a encore des sujets en
rédigeant fils richard vous n'êtes pas
d'accord didier martin réponses courtes
s'il vous plaît non mais si ces critères
ont été effectivement sorti les sorties
cp on ne pouvait pas les mesures et
septième en cinq volumes c'est une ville
à gages
par contre là où je vous rejoins
mesdames c'est que il ya certainement
par rapport aux critères qui reste des
choses à imaginer pour déceler pour
mesurer effectivement la véritable
pénibilité des gens qui exercent
certains métiers mais il faut il faut
travailler sur les facteurs espèrent
mais il faut pas réinventer
on est d'accord que le port de charges
lourdes vibrations les produits
chimiques
est ce que ce sont des poids l'emploi
des seniors la pénibilité l'égalité
hommes femmes est ce que ce sont des
points qui si il ya des avancées du côté
du gouvernement pourrait faire que la
cgt sortent du contrat n'a pour le
moment
les lois parce que le coeur du système
pour le moment c'est pas d'améliorer le
niveau des pensions parce qu'on parle du
système par appât du système de
retraites c'est pas d'améliorer le
niveau des pensions c'est de faire des
économies et le gouvernement en
dénonçant le prouve qu'en bien entendu
non ce n'est pas faire des économies
c'est de pérenniser l'avenir de nos
retraites bien je n'ai pas de faire des
économies nous course à quoi aujourd'hui
14 % de la richesse nationale voulait
bloquer ce qu' il est un des plus hauts
dans les pays de l' ocde 14% dans mieux
nous nous en félicitons nous décidons de
ne pas aller au delà pourquoi parce
qu'il ya d'autres investissements
indispensables à faire dans ce pays sur
la vire là encore sur la recherche sur
la performance et la compétitivité sur
l'éducation
nous augmentons les emplois dans le
service public de l'éducation nationale
sur martin puis j'allais juste ballon
mais dans la danse manger m'avait coupé
monsieur marche que j'étais un peu c'est
vrai qu'il nous reste sa longue relation
donc ça va les tribus latin quand on
bloque les ressources et que l'on sait
que la démographie fait que on sera de
plus en plus nombreux à la retraite et
tant mieux
forcément quand on garde la meynard
bloqué par les ressources elles vont
elles mont blanc a augmenté avec la
crise la reprise ne vous bloquer les
niveaux d'organisation et nous ne
voulons ni votre quotidien voulons ni
pénaliser d'emploi ni pénaliser les
investissements
c'est pour cela que nous ne dépassons
pas cette limite qui est raisonnable
alors qui est responsable de ce
mouvement qui perdure aujourd'hui
d'abord est-ce qu'il va perdurer sans
vie de mourir en un mot alors là pour le
moment effectivement oui puisque les
organisations syndicales je rappelle les
organisations syndicales de jeunesse les
organisations cgt fo solidaires fsu et
la cfe cgc appelle effectivement un nous
voilà des deux journées de mobilisation
le 14 le 15 sur d'autres formes et le 16
janvier alors quel est le principal
responsable de ce mouvement je vous
propose de regarder ce sondage ipsos
sopra steria réalisée pour france
télévision 40 2 % des français
interrogés pensent que c'est la faute du
gouvernement et en même temps les
syndicats ne sont pas épargnés vous le
voyez 31% pour les syndicats didier
martin
oui là on n'est pas sorti j'entends
conflit en journée nouvelle opinions
s'expriment le pinho d'abord faut pas
oublier cette mesure a été proposée par
le président de la république quand il
était candidat
donc ce gouvernement il gère le national
organe une promesse présidentielle
réformer les retraites en gardant la
répartition en le diminuant pas le
niveau des prestations servies
mais en évoluant vers un système à
points donc on change le système vers
quelque chose qui nous paraît plus juste
je le dis tout à l'heure je ne vais pas
me répéter
cependant il faut dans un esprit de
responsabilité et non pas de faute et
nous savons que ça peut contrarier
certains mais en responsabilité
il faut arrêter avec les régimes
spéciaux faire que les petites retraites
et ce qui manque le plus certes
davantage sur les coûts vous vous accuse
de niveler par le bas
quand vous dites faut mettre fin au
régime la solidarité c'est pas des blés
par le bas c'est traiter en priorité les
personnes qui en retraite n'arrivent pas
à joindre les deux monsieur martin on va
créer combien de régimes spéciaux parce
que à chaque année le l'enveloppent elle
va elle va être fonction du nombre de
bises à part créé d'ailleurs en
détricotant finalement le projet de loi
au fur à mesure les pilotes de ligne on
n'a rien détricoter le projet de loi est
là encore pas été présenté au conseil
des ministres
oui milliards étaient soumis au conseil
d'état ya pas d nous ayons régimes
spéciaux là qu'ils sont nous les avons
une quinzaine aurait demandé contre la
rage
l'émission est danseur et galeries dont
l'édition régaliennes ce qui nous
protège tous la police la gendarmerie le
contrôle aérien
il y a des spécificités que vous devez
reconnaître les et nathalie au delà du
conflit sur les retraites on voit bien
que pour l'instant tout n'est pas réglé
même si laurent berger de la cgt tend la
main au gouvernement de la cfdt tend la
main au gouvernement
est ce que vous voyez vous dans les mois
à venir d'autres sources de conflits
sociaux on penche notamment aux conflits
d urgence on en a parlé ici dans cette
émission qui n'est toujours pas réglée
est ce que vous pensez que le conflit
social le combat social n'est pas
terminée en 2020 mais je pense que le
combat social il est
existe depuis depuis 2018 et il va se
continuer jusqu'à 2022 parce que à
chaque réforme on va s'apercevoir qu'il
va y avoir un conflit et des
dysfonctionnements au niveau des
urgences et au niveau de l'hôpital lady
fondent les dysfonctionnements sont
patents dire on a au moins deux services
publics moins de soins une meilleure
moins bonne qualité du soin et mais on
se demande si emmanuel macron va
continuer sur d'autres réforme sur
l'audiovisuel ou sur la sécurité sociale
alors moi je n'anticipe aller les
contenus mais force est de constater que
depuis le début du quinquennat
les choses sont pas très positif dit
martin est ce que après le conflit des
gilles et jo le conflit des retraites le
gouvernement va lever le pied sur les
réformes en prévision de l'élection
présidentielle ou bien ce que jeune ça
va continuer à toute allure à je ne
pense pas on n'est pas toute allure on
est mesurée pour les urgences les
urgences médicales et l'hôpital
moi je te fait toute ma carrière
l'hôpital je vois très bien où sur les
problèmes et des mesures d'urgence
les analyses mais maintenant on vise à
augmenter de 90 euros les personnes qui
travaillent aux urgences et je pense en
particulier à ma discipline qui
travaillent nuit et jour la radiologie
parce que c'est indispensable au
diagnostic en urgence
donc il y a des solutions la solution
system x et davantage de personnel et
meilleure organisation vous l'avez dit
monsieur meilleure organisation ma
question c'est des organisations
professionnelles de territoire qui
doivent éviter là encore je vous allez
continuer les répondants les étudiants
et les réformes vont prochainement froid
dit l'audio pas du tout
le neuvième duel est annoncé à un projet
de loi sur le grand âge et l'autonomie
est annoncé normal à buzeins je ne
contiendront à réformer pour les france
merci d'avoir accepté de débattre en
direct ce matin merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis dans un instant à quoi sur
l'actualité régionale avec marie joly
puis la partie nationale de dimanche en
politique francis letellier reçoit
patrick kanner le président du groupe
socialiste au sénat bon dimanche à tous
sur france 3
[Musique]